للمره الاولى منذ الحرب على قطاع غزه قال
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان منزلا في
مستوطنه ميراف شرق مدينه جنين تعرض لاطلاق
نار دون وقوع اصابات واضاف ان قوته تمشط
بل تمشط المنطقه بحثا عن منفذ عمليه اطلاق
النار موضحا ان قواته ردت على الفور على
مصدر اطلاق النار واقتحمت قريه جلبون شرقي
مدينه جنين بحثا عن
المنفذين
نشرت منصات محليه مشاهد يسمع فيها دوي
اشتباكات بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده اليمون شمال
غرب جنين وكانت قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت فجر
اليوم قر عده في محيط جنين وسط استمرار
حملتها العسكريه على مدن وقرى الضفه
الغربيه كما اشارت مصادر محليه الى وقوع
اشتباكات بين مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال على
الطريق بين بلده اليمون والسله الحارثيه
شمال غرب جنينين